la liberté de la presse est un pilier de
la démocratie et il importe de la
préserver en Europe et dans notre pays
en ces temps où la démocratie est remise
en cause dans ces dans ces fondements à
nos frontières même et d'entendre pays
d'entendre pays du monde et à l'heure où
la désinformation se répand partout sur
les réseaux sociaux nous étions hier
dans une réunion à Matignon avec la
première ministre et l'un des piliers
sur en fait sur le comité
de cohésion entre France et Ukraine donc
avec à la fois les militaires mais aussi
les politiques et le pilier de la
désinformation et a été évoquée de façon
de façon très importante et très
prégnante la commission des affaires
européennes que j'ai l'honneur de
présider à désigner trois rapporteurs il
y a Florence blatrix compta André
gatolin et Catherine Morin de saillie
sur le règlement que la Commission
européenne propose pour créer un cadre
législatif européen
humain sur la liberté des médias
l'objectif est louable garantir
l'indépendance des médias notamment en
contrôlant les concentrations entre
organes de presse le texte instituerait
pour cela un comité de régulation
européen chargé de préserver le
pluralisme du paysage médiatique
européen ce qui est assez novateur par
rapport à notre propre système national
de régulation des médias
nous rapporteurs reviendrons dans un
instant en introduction de cette table
ronde sur le contenu de ce texte et ses
enjeux sur lesquels il est crucial pour
nous législateur d'échanger avec vous
professionnelle de la presse écrite et
en ligne en partant de votre expérience
de votre vécu de vos aspirations et de
vos souhaits c'est l'objectif de cette
table ronde permettez-moi auparavant de
rappeler que la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat après préalablement
contrôler la conformité de cette
proposition législative européenne au
principe de subsidiarité en effet les
traités fondateurs européens confie au
Parlement nationaux le soin de vérifier
que l'Union européenne reste bien dans
son rôle intervient à bon escient et
évite l'excès de réglementation à ce
titre la commission que je préside
reçoit toutes les propositions
législatives de la Commission européenne
elle existe examine sous cet angle la
plupart respectent la répartition des
compétences entre l'Union européenne et
ses États membres fixés dans les traités
mais il arrive que ce ne soit pas le cas
nous proposons alors au Sénat de le
dénoncer en adoptant un avis motivé qui
alerte sur le risque que l'Union
européenne aille trop loin dans ses
compétences c'est ce que nous avons jugé
utile de faire concernant cette
initiative sur une régulation européenne
de la liberté des médias notre
commission a donc adopté à l'unanimité
une proposition d'avis motivé qui est
devenue résolution définitive du Sénat
le 11 décembre dernier
selon nous en effet le texte présenté
par la Commission européenne n'est pas
conforme à ce praticide de prudence et
d'équilibre qui doit borner les
initiatives du législateur européen et
préserver la marge de manœuvre des
parlements nationaux nos rapporteurs
reviendront sans doute sur les motifs de
cette décision qui ne contestent
nullement les intentions les objectifs
ou le font même du texte mais qui
discutent sa valeur ajoutée par rapport
à un cadre législatif national déjà très
développé en France et qui interroge sa
base sa base juridique la Commission
européenne fondant son initiative sur le
seuil article 114 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
destiné à assurer le fonctionnement du
marché intérieur or s'il existe un
marché intérieur des médias en Europe
celui-ci n'échappe pas une segmentation
nationale culturelle et linguistique qui
justifient tout autant d'invoquer
l'article 176 du même traité lequel
appelle au respect de la diversité
culturelle et des législations
nationales cela méritait d'être souligné
par le Sénat à présent nous sommes très
heureux de démarrer avec vous ce matin
et en commun avec la commission culture
et son président Laurent Lafont l'examen
au fond de ce projet de règlement
européen qui aura sans doute de profonde
répercussions sur votre secteur Laurent
merci monsieur le Président cher
Jean-François en effet avec le président
de la commission des affaires
européennes nous avons souhaité ce matin
consacrer une matinée à ce texte
important sur la liberté des médias en
Europe ce règlement dit européen média
freedom Act c'est une méthode que nous
allons bien ici au Sénat à savoir
anticiper et non pas subir la
législation européenne et je remercie la
commission tes affaires européennes pour
le choix de cette thématique et le
travail qui va vous être présenté dans
un instant par la rapporteur qui a donné
lieu à cette résolution le projet dont
nous allons débattre recoupe largement
plusieurs enjeux sur lequel la
commission de la culture a eu à se
prononcer ces dernières années je vais
pas les rappeler de manière exhaustive
mais en plus des travaux de notre
rapporteur que je cherchais du regard
Michel Laugier rapporteur pour les
budgétaires pour les sur la presse je
pense en particulier aux travaux que
qu'avaient mené Catherine Morin de
saillie travaux pionniers sur le sujet
sur la régulation dans le secteur du
numérique et la lutte contre les fausses
informations et la haine en ligne
qui sont des préoccupations partagées au
niveau du continent bien entendu je
pense également à la loi adopter sur les
droits voisins des éditeurs et des
agences de presse qui constituent la
transposition française du d'une
directive nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec certains d'entre vous à
plusieurs reprises et enfin à la
commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des des médias
David hassouline en était le rapporteur
et j'en étais le président
commission qui a travaillé l'année
dernière et qui a établi un
panorama panorama pardon très large dans
toute l'Europe des différences approches
mais également des convergences sur ces
problématiques ces sujets constituent le
cœur même du projet de règlement
européen sur lequel nous allons débattre
ce matin cependant tel que tel quel des
projets posent en effet de redoutable
difficulté le président Rapin vient de
les rappeler elles sont d'ordre
juridique comme la commission des
affaires européennes la relevée dans en
adoptant le 8 décembre dernier la
proposition de résolution de Florence
blatrix contact Catherine Morin de
saillie et d'André gatelin qui soulève
une sérieuse réserve sur la base
juridique du texte mais les difficultés
relèvent également des principes dans
quelle mesure le projet de règlement
est-il compatible avec les fondements de
notre droit et je pense en particulier à
la loi de 1881 et également à celle de
1986 sur l'audiovisuel
je remercie nos intervenants à qui nous
allons donner la parole dans quelques
instants mais avant nous allons donner
la parole à
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
européennes pour qu'ils présentent leur
résolution on fait comme ça
Jean-François
on vous donne la parole je vous
présenterai après alors dans un
merci monsieur le Président Messieurs
les Présidents mesdames Messieurs mes
chers collègues nous entamons avec cette
audition collective dont je me réjouis
l'examen au fond d'un texte dense touffu
et complexe la proposition de règlement
du Parlement européen et du Conseil du
16 septembre 2022 qui a pour objet
d'établir un cadre européen commun de
régulation de l'ensemble du secteur du
média porté par la vice-présidence de la
Commission européenne chargée des
valeurs et de la transparence madame
vera Yoroba et le commissaire français
au marché intérieur Monsieur Thierry
Breton il met en oeuvre l'engagement
politique pris par la présidence madame
Ursula vanderlione qui avait annoncé
cette initiative dans son discours sur
l'état de l'Union de 2021 et bien
indiqué les médias ne sont pas des
entreprises comme les autres leur
indépendance est essentielle voilà
pourquoi l'Europe a besoin d'une loi qui
garantit cette indépendance l'année
prochaine nous présenterons précisément
une telle loi sur la liberté des médias
elle a figuré effectivement dans le
programme de travail de la commission
pour 2022 donc elle prolonge un paquet
de mesures cela a été dit destiné d'une
part à réguler le cadre d'exercice des
services numériques et des services des
médias et d'autre part à défendre la
liberté de la presse conformément au
plan d'action de la Commission
européenne pour la démocratie européenne
tout en établissant un nouveau cadre
législatif commun et harmoniser d'un
marché intérieur des services de médias
c'est donc un texte aux objectifs
louables ambitieux mais disparate cela a
été dit nous partageons l'objectif
principal de cette nouvelle proposition
de législation européenne il s'agit au
vu des constats qui ont pu être fait
depuis quelques années dans quelques
pays de l'Union européenne récemment
notamment en Pologne en Hongrie de
renforcer la liberté et l'indépendance
éditoriale des entreprises de médias en
recommandant des financements dédiés aux
médias de services publics des mesures
sur l'attribution équit ables et
transparente de la publicité des règles
sur la transparence de la propriété des
organes de presse et un contrôle
déconcentrations ce texte institut pour
cela un comité de régulation européen
qui jouerait également un rôle
spécifique dans la lutte contre la
désinformation ce comité se
substituerait au groupe des régulateurs
européens pour les services de médias
audiovisuel larga
institué par la directive SMA et il
aurait compétence pour protéger toutes
les entreprises de médias contre des
mesures nationales injustifiées
disproportionné et discriminatoire afin
de préserver le pluralisme d'un paysage
médiatique européen de garantir son bon
fonctionnement et de renforcer la
protection de l'État de droit que cette
préoccupation que cette inquiétude que
cette nécessité d'agir soit largement
partagée au niveau européen cela ne fait
guère de doute mais comme vient de
l'indiquer le président Rapin la base
juridique de l'article 114 destiné à
assurer le fonctionnement optimal du
marché intérieur des services de média
nous a paru contestables en effet la
plupart des pays européens ont mis en
place de longues dates des règles
spécifiques nationales pour réguler le
secteur et particulièrement dans notre
pays comme bien le dire de le préciser
le président la fin ne nous y trompons
pas la commission européenne propose un
nouvel accroissement du champ des
compétences matérielles du législateur
européen au détriment des Parlement
nationaux ce constat est au cœur de
notre avis motivé sur la non conformité
aux principes de subsidiarité je vais
laisser mon collègue André pour chien
merci Florence en effet notre grande loi
sur la presse la loi du 29 juillet
1989 1980 devrait au terme de de ce
texte il était adopté sans doute être
amendé
et dans son état actuel puisque s'il est
dispositions notamment des articles 4 et
des articles 6 l'article 4 et celui qui
élargit la protection des sources des
journalistes et c'est une bonne chose
l'article 6 celui qui se réfère à un
indépendance éditoriale donc nous
aurions à réviser ces ce texte
fondamental c'est pas un problème en soi
et ça serait même plutôt une bonne chose
en termes d'apport mais il reste quand
même des points nous semble dans le
libellé actuel de du projet de
règlement
quelques interrogations notamment ces
articles mettent en jeu la
responsabilité pénale de ce qui est
appelé les chefs de rédaction
terminologie donc proposé par la
Commission qui demanderait d'ailleurs
être précisé au regard du droit français
puisque nous parlons plutôt de directeur
de la publication en matière de
responsabilité
juridique il y a également dans ce cadre
un point d'interrogation on pourrait
même dire peut-être de suspicion quand
elle a validité d'un tel réglement de
fait le cadre européen qui est envisagé
ici par la commission s'inspire quasi
exclusivement de la réglementation
audiovisuelle au lieu de reconnaître les
spécificités sectorielles de la presse
le texte vise à les soumettre à quatre
communs avec l'audiovisuel or s'il est
possible dans une certaine mesure de
justifier l'existence d'un marché unique
dans l'Union européenne pour les
services audiovisuels il nous a paru
plus contestable de postuler l'existence
d'un marché européen pour la presse
compte tenu de l'importance des
différences culturelles et linguistiques
entre les États membres et là ça a été
rappelé la base juridique utilisée et
celle de l'article 114 du traité de
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
donc est celui qui gère le marché unique
alors que nous avons aussi d'autres
articles comme le 177 qui traite de la
diversité culturelle le premier est de
compétences exclusives de l'Union et de
la commission le second est une
compétence partagée et on sent bien
qu'il y a une volonté je dirais de la
commission d'utiliser la base juridique
qui lui donne le plus le pouvoir mais
dans un champ et dans une approche
évidemment plus économique et plus
marché que débat public ou respect de la
diversité culturelle par ailleurs nous
nous interrogeons sur l'articulation de
ce texte avec trois les trois principaux
textes européens qui constituent la base
de l'acquis communautaire en matière de
régulation des médias le premier c'est
naturellement la directive sur les
services médias audiovisuels la
directive SMA il y a également la
directive établissant des règles sur
l'exercice du droit d'auteur et des
droits voisins applicables à certaines
transmissions en ligne d'organismes de
radio de fusion et de retransmission de
programme de télévision et de radio
c'est la fameuse directive Capsa 2 qui
nous concerne moins puisque là on est
dans le débat plutôt concernant la
presse écrite et enfin le règlement
relatif au marché unique des services
numériques le DSA la proposition nous
examinons aujourd'hui est en effet très
imprécise dans son articulation avec la
directive SMA qu'elle est censée
pourtant prolonger en tous les cas selon
les dires de la Commission européenne or
les définitions proposées devraient être
intrigue allemand harmonisé avec celle
de la directive SMA en particulier pour
les services de médias mais aussi pour
les notions de responsabilité et de
décision éditoriale l'article 6 du
règlement qui concerne notamment le
niveau de protection applicable au
fournisseurs des services médias et
d'actualité ne tient aucun compte des
dispositions existantes dans ce domaine
dans la directive SMA il en va de même
des dispositions obligatoires sur
l'organisation éditoriale des médias aux
articles 7 et suivants qui portent sur
le rôle des autorités de régulation
ces articles prévoient la création d'un
comité européen au passage d'ailleurs
nous sommes inquiétés de la traduction
du terme de la première formulation qui
parle en anglais de board qui exprime un
conseil mais beaucoup plus puissant donc
un comité et un board ce n'est pas tout
à fait la même chose en tous les cas
c'est l'équivalence qui a donné pour
l'instant la Commission à ces deux
termes
et cette proposition de règlement du
coup modifie de façon importante
l'équilibre entre les autorités
nationales et les autorités européennes
tout en prévoyant que la Commission
européenne en assure le secrétariat au
niveau européen c'est évidemment l'un de
nos points de vigilance essentielle
quand à la comptabilité compatibilité
pardon avec le DSA l'article 17 la
proposition de règlement prévoit un
nouveau mécanisme destiné à éviter une
double modération des contenus publiés
ou édités par les médias de fait il
acheteur une obligation pour les
fournisseurs de très grandes plateformes
de mettre à disposition des utilisateurs
un formulaire de déclaration en tant que
fournisseur de services de médias afin
de bénéficier de modalités de modération
spécifique il s'agit là encore d'une
modification significative des
dispositions du DSA alors que ce dernier
n'est même pas encore entré en
application
il est indispensable je crois de lever
ces ambiguïtés pour coordonner et
articuler cette proposition avec le DSA
qui vient d'être adopté il nous a donc
semblé que dans son projet la Commission
européenne allait un peu trop loin et un
peu trop vite dans son ambition
législative en assimilant la régulation
des médias locaux et culturels de presse
au développement d'un marché intérieur
des médias dans l'audiovisuel et le
numérique il importe enfin de rappeler
en ma qualité de sénateur membre de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe la PCE le rôle de cette
institution auprès de laquelle
d'ailleurs l'Association des
journalistes européens que vous
représentez ici à chaque Catherine André
et reconnu comme observateur en effet le
Conseil de l'Europe a adopté plusieurs
conventions je crois très pertinentes
dans le domaine de la protection du
pluralisme et de la liberté des médias
la PCE est très active pour ne citer que
deux exemple relativement récent elle
adoptait en janvier 2020 une résolution
sur les menaces sur la liberté des
médias et la sécurité des journalistes
en Europe et en juin 2022 une résolution
sur le contrôle de la communication en
ligne une menace pour le pluralisme des
médias la liberté d'information et la
dignité humaine et là la présente
proposition de règlement ne mentionne
nullement le Conseil de l'Europe néglige
d'encourager l'Union européenne et ses
États membres à coopérer avec cette
institution particulièrement attentive
au respect des droits des journalistes
et des médias c'est pourquoi nous avons
dans notre avis motivé inclut cette
référence lorsque nous l'avons adopté en
décembre dernier nous avons maintenant
hâte de vous entendre et d'échanger avec
vous sur vos réactions vos analyses vos
expériences par rapport à ce projet je
vous remercie merci vous voyez que à ce
stade le projet de règlement soulève de
nombreuses questions côté et je ne doute
pas qu'elle vous interroge aussi et bien
sûr nous sommes très nombreux comme
André gatelin vient de le dire de vous
entendre et d'échanger avec vous avant
de vous donner la parole je vais quand
même vous présenter en commençant par
Jean-Pierre de keraoul président de
sogemmedia président de l'Association
européenne des éditeurs et de la
commission juridique de l'alliance de la
presse d'information générale la pige
madame Cécile Dubois qui est
cofondatrice et rédactrice de en chef de
94 citoyens et qu'au président du
Syndicat de la presse indépendante
d'information en ligne Le Spiel Monsieur
Patrick Evenot président d'observatoire
de la déontologie de l'information non
corrigée alors si nous sommes trompés
a disparu quand a été créé le conseil de
déontologie journalistique et médiation
que j'ai fondée dont j'étais le
président et donc je suis ex-président
de l'Observatoire et ex-président du
cdjm mais je reste toujours et avant
tout historien des médias titulaires
d'une chaire à la Sorbonne même si
maintenant je suis professeur émérite
très bien merci d'avoir corrigé
Christophe Deloire qui est président de
reporter sans frontières et président
dans cette salle pour ne pas en rajouter
moi je suis directeur général et
secrétaire général
écoutez je crois ne pas me tromper en
disant que Madame Catherine André et
vice-présidente de l'Association des
journalistes européens et d'actrices en
chef adjointe d'alternative économique
co-fondatrice et directrice de Vox
Europe c'est exact merci vous m'avez
rattrapé dernier moment
sans plus tarder je vais vous donner la
parole je ne sais pas qui commence
monsieur
entendu à votre condense madame la
jonatrice mesdames les génératrice
Messieurs les Présidents et je fais
cours pour aller tout de suite au sujet
les éditeurs de presse européen
partagent évidemment le souci de la
Commission et non évidemment aucune
aucune réserve sur les intentions du
projet je crois que c'est un point qui
nous rassemble tous et je dirais que
prévenir les risques d'ingérence
extérieurs garantir l'indépendance des
médias assurer une meilleure
transparence on a évidemment aucun
problème là-dessus et sur plusieurs des
mesures envisagées dans le texte actuel
nous avons également aucune objection
pour autant que poursuivent les
objectifs et effectivement mentionnés à
l'instant nous avons comme vous le savez
vous l'avez déjà évoqué trois sujets de
préoccupation principaux le premier
c'est le fameux article 6
qui dans sa rédaction actuelle avec
effectivement des difficultés un peu de
traduction
revient à confier semble-t-il au
rédacteur en chef l'ensemble des
décisions éditoriales ce qui revient en
France par exemple à privé le directeur
de publications ce qui est en anglais de
pablisher
de sa capacité effective à diriger notre
sentiment qui est je crois quand même
une affaire de bon sens c'est qu'on ne
peut pas disjoindre l'autorité et la
responsabilité dans aucune situation
donc si on demande conformément à la loi
de 1880 à au directeur des publications
d'être
civilement pénalement et personnellement
responsable de l'intégralité du contenu
de sa publication on ne peut pas le
priver d'un pouvoir d'intervention de
direction effective au quotidien de sa
publication j'ajoute par parenthèse que
comme vous le savez en France la loi
maintenant
s'impose à toutes les publications
d'avoir une charte éditoriale qui est
préalablement négocié entre les
journalistes et l'éditeurs donc de ce
point de vue il nous semble vraiment
problématique de d'introduire cette
nouveauté qui serait qui reviendrait en
fait à disjoindre autorité et
responsabilité et effectivement nous
contrôlerait à modifier la loi de 1880
donc
l'éditeur en réalité ne l'oublions pas
dans l'immense majorité des cas et je
conviens tout à fait qu'il peut y avoir
de temps en temps de malheureusement
mais dans l'immense majorité des cas et
je peux vous le dire en tant qu'aditeur
personnellement des journalistes de dans
la presse régionale il est le premier
défenseur de la liberté de la presse et
il est le premier rempart de ces
journalistes donc donner le sentiment
que il y a sur ces sujets une sorte de
conflit structurel entre l'éditeur et le
et les journalistes est assez artificiel
et d'ailleurs il est frappant de voir
que dans le projet de texte nulle part
je dis bien nulle part on ne parle de
l'éditeur nulle part il y a publisher ou
éditeur on fait comme si le problème
était exclusivement entre des
actionnaires chez à les journalistes or
en France et dans tous les pays
européens évidemment l'entreprise de
presse elle est pilotée par un éditeur
et qui en France a des responsabilités
extrêmement claires voilà donc ça c'est
c'est un sujet qu'il faut qu'il faudra
traiter effectivement le fait que ça
soit envisagé dans le cas d'un règlement
et problématique il est envisagé comme
vous savez aujourd'hui c'est discuter au
Parlement européen où nous étions la
semaine dernière peut-être de
séparer le texte actuel en une version
qui se relèverait d'une directive et une
partie du règlement la difficulté si
c'est si ça reste un règlement c'est
qu'il est d'applications immédiate et
que donc en France par exemple nous
n'aurions pas la possibilité d'adapter
les principes généraux qui pourraient
parfaitement être mis dans une directive
relative à l'indépendance des rédactions
des médias à la liberté des journalistes
etc on pourrait très bien avoir des
principes généraux qui pourraient être
traduit transposer dans la loi française
de telle sorte qu'il reste compatible
avec la loi 1881 mais malheureusement si
c'est un règlement ça ça obligera à
modifier deuxième difficulté c'est
l'article 17 ou les grandes plateformes
ont aujourd'hui le pouvoir de modifier
unilatéralement ou de supprimer des
contenus de presse ce qui est évidemment
parfaitement inacceptable même si on
envisage que ça soit après avoir
simplement informé le titre
ça pose de il y a deux difficultés la
première c'est qu'il faudrait que les
éditeurs des sites en question se
déclarent auprès des grandes plateformes
et que donc les se déclare en tant que
publication et que les grandes
plateformes seraient les juges en
réalité de ce qu'est de la presse et ce
qui
évidemment totalement inacceptable qu'en
fonction de l'humeur de Monsieur musk
qui est comme vous savez assez variable
d'un jour à l'autre on puisse dire bah
oui c'est celui-là c'est de la presse
puis je suis là c'est pas de la presse
bon il y a aucune légitimité à ça donc
il faut trouver une formule de
labellisation c'est pas simple parce que
les situations sont différentes d'un
pays à l'autre en France nous avons la
chance d'avoir la commission paritaire
les publications et agence de presse qui
dit ce qui est de la presse et ce qui
est pas de la presse et que nous venons
de renforcer récemment dans son autorité
par exemple avec des exigences d'emploi
de journalistes ce qui est très bien
pour valider qu'une entreprise de presse
qui prétendette les effectivement il
peut pas y avoir nos yeux d'entreprises
de presse qui n'emploie pas de
journalistes donc cet instant de
commission paritaire qui a une
légitimité politique et professionnelle
et elle est composée de représentants
des ministres et des représentants des
professionnels et elle joue son rôle et
il y a malheureusement pas toujours
l'équivalent dans les autres pays donc
on dit en France labellisation c'est
très naturellement à la commission
paritaire s'il y a des équivalents dans
d'autres pays on pourrait considérer que
ce sont ces équivalents aussi qui
valides à défaut il peut y avoir
d'autres instances qui ont été évoqués
le JTI ou autre qui qui pourrait jouer
ce rôle à condition à nos yeux
qu'effectivement les éditeurs de presse
dans leur responsabilités ils souhaitent
associés parce qu'on peut difficilement
imaginer qu'une instance labellisante
n'est pas de légitimité à la fois
démocratique et professionnelle donc il
faut résoudre le problème de légitimité
mais nous éditeur de presse européen
nous sommes tout à fait ouvert à
différentes possibilités de
labellisation à condition que ça soit
pas les plateformes qui s'y substitue
évidemment il est le deuxième point pas
acceptable que il y ait une décision
sans procédure contradictoire il va de
soi que si une plateforme considère
qu'elle doit supprimer
un contenu de presse euh qui serait
contradict contraire à ces Conditions
Générales d'Utilisation c'est pas c'est
pas un critère acceptable il faut qu'il
y ait une procédure contradictoire il
faut qu'elle informe de son intention de
suppression et l'éditeur et que
l'éditeur et la possibilité de répondre
et qu'à défaut est qu'à défaut que ça
soit le juge judiciaire qui tranche et
non pas la plateforme comme dans la
version actuelle dernier point le fameux
Conseil européen des médias je serai
bref là dessus il nous semble que dans
son sa définition actuelle il a pas
vraiment de justification à s'occuper de
l'affaire de presse écrite autant comme
vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur le
Président il peut se justifier quand on
parle d'audiovisuel en matière de presse
écrite on voit pas bien qu'elle serait
sa compétence et j'ai d'ailleurs
remarqué que l'art comme qui serait
supposé être notre représentant français
au sein du Board a bien fait savoir
qu'elle souhaitait absolument pas elle
n'a pas de compétences en matière et
elle souhaite absolument pas en avoir au
total je crois que il faut pas mettre en
place des mauvaises solutions pour
résoudre devrait problème oui il y a des
problèmes de liberté de la presse oui il
y a des journalistes menacées oui dans
certains pays européens la liberté de la
presse n'est pas respectée nous avons eu
récemment même en France avec le cas
d'un hebdo en Bretagne des menaces sur
des menaces de mort sur des journalistes
donc nous éditeurs de presse sommes
totalement solidaires de nos
journalistes évidemment pour protéger
leur liberté et leur capacité à exercer
leur métier mais n'invantons pas un
marché intérieur des des la presse
écrite qui n'existe pas pour résoudre ce
problème
ne n'oublions pas que la vraie menace
sur l'économie de la presse aujourd'hui
c'est la puissance considérable des
grandes plateformes et que donc le vrai
sujet c'est comment on rééquilibre cette
puissance entre les grandes plateformes
et les éditeurs de qui soit digitaux
écrits ou les deux
et donc enfin quand il s'agit de liberté
de la presse
n'imaginons pas que on l'a on
l'améliorera en séparant les éditeurs
des journalistes l'éditeur comme je le
disais il est le premier rempart des
journalistes on est ensemble face à un
tel défi
démocratique industrielle
professionnelle dans le déséquilibre de
puissance entre les grandes plateformes
et la presse que c'est vraiment pas le
moment ni les uns ni les autres d'avoir
des postures nous devons nous battre
ensemble journaliste et éditeur pour
sauver la presse la renouveler et lui
permettre de jouer son rôle au service
de la démocratie
merci madame Cécile Dubois
c'est bon oui merci
nous on trouve ce règlement alors on
partage globalement les lignes rouges
que vous avez évoquées un certain nombre
de lignes rouges que vous avez évoquées
on trouve malgré tout ce règlement quand
même très intéressant dans ces dans ces
objets c'est à dire se protéger de
gouvernement libéraux de régimes
libéraux il y en a plusieurs en Europe
et on n'est pas à l'abri même en France
un jour de se retrouver dans un régime
il libéral et donc il n'est pas
inintéressant en France de s'interroger
à cette possible configuration qui
puisse arriver un jour et donc de voir
comment aussi en France on pourrait se
prémunir d'un éventu de l'arrivée
éventuelle d'un régime médéral et
comment l'Europe pourrait peut-être nous
aider en ce sens donc le fait même de se
poser la question y compris en France
même si on est très protégé même si on a
d'excellents plats comme la loi de 1881
qui reste un pilier c'est pas
inintéressant
et l'autre point c'est le dialogue avec
les plateformes ça reste évidemment
aussi un très gros sujet pour nous c'est
l'un des principaux sujets ce sont les
plateformes avec lesquelles il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
dialogue puisque c'est forcément
complètement
disproportion on n'est pas du tout dans
les mêmes dans les mêmes rapports de
force même un syndicat d'éditeur
vis-à-vis d'une plateforme même
plusieurs syndicats d'éditeurs au niveau
d'un pays c'est extrêmement compliqué
en ce sens le règlement nous semble
apporter des des pistes intéressantes et
à commencer par ce super comité qui qui
ambitionne de développer un dialogue
peut-être un peu plus suivi aussi avec
les plateformes qui ne soit pas
seulement un règlement de temps en temps
avec des décisions coupées mais
peut-être la possibilité d'un dialogue
constructif avec les plateformes
auxquelles pourraient participer
les tous les pays les éditeurs les
syndicats d'éditeurs la réserve qu'on a
par rapport à ce à ce super comité c'est
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est ça se présente comme un
super comité vous avez rappelé monsieur
le sénateur que le la proposition du
règlement était même que le secrétariat
soit assuré par la Commission européenne
donc là vraiment on se dit que c'est
complètement téléguidé par la Commission
européenne et c'est un problème là on
est on est complètement d'accord donc ce
je parle je profite pour rappeler que le
Spil fait partie d'une association
européenne qui s'appelle news media
Europe qui a fait un certain nombre de
propositions un certain nombre
d'amendements et cette association a
fait à proposer notamment comme
amendement de d'intégrer dessiner des
éditeurs des représentants d'éditeurs
des représentants de syndicats
d'éditeurs ou d'associations d'éditeurs
dans ce super comité dans la gouvernance
de ce super comité nous speed is
souscrivons complètement
l'élargir cette gouvernance non
seulement aux autorités locales mais
aussi à des à des représentants des des
éditeurs nous semblerait peut-être de
nature à rééquilibrer un peu le pouvoir
de ce de ce comité et en tout cas bien
évidemment son secrétariat ne doit pas
être attiré par la Commission européenne
mais il doit vraiment avoir être
indépendant dans sa dans son
fonctionnement
concernant les les l'autre lignes rouges
on partage
quasiment entièrement aussi avec
Jean-Pierre de karaudes c'est
évidemment l'article 6a et
l'indépendance la manière dont il est
actuellement rédigé d'indépendance des
rédactions et c'est même au-delà de
l'indépendance des rédactions c'est
rédigé d'une manière qui laisse entendre
que le rédacteur en chef peut prendre
des décisions individuelles et que
l'éditeur n'a rien à y voir ce qui pose
vraiment vraiment là un problème
un problème dans l'organisation le bon
fonctionnement d'une rédaction de
problèmes principaux comme la comme l'a
rappelé Jean-Pierre de carou le problème
juridique c'est que on a une loi 1880
qui protège les journalistes grâce
justement aux éditeurs qui portent le
chapeau le directeur de publication qui
porte juridiquement qui porte la
responsabilité juridique des propos des
textes du contenu des journalistes donc
il est absolument nécessaire de
préserver ça et puis sur le plan
financier tout simplement aussi c'est
déjà très compliqué pour la presse un
secteur qui est fragile donc fragiliser
les éditeurs en en
les empêchant de pouvoir
maîtriser leurs lignes éditoriale mais
ça coupait définitivement
l'investissement dans toutes les
entreprises de presse donc c'est
vraiment la fin
d'un financement pérenne de la presse et
ce serait d'ailleurs complètement non
productif puisque finalement
il y aurait des influences qui
s'exprimeraient autrement c'est à dire
que il n'empêche pas non plus de on peut
toujours virer son rédaction donc
l'influence finalement s'exprimerait
autrement et ça n'aurait même pas
forcément une efficacité très grande
l'amendement qu'on a auquel on souscrit
qui a été porté par news media Europe
sur cet article 6a c'est de
permettre une certaine marge de
manoeuvre de permettre des décisions et
marge de manœuvre bien évidemment de la
rédaction mais dans le cadre d'une ligne
éditoriale décidé avec l'éditeur enfin
décidé par l'éditeur c'est à dire c'est
la ligne éditoriale de l'éditeur c'est
lui qui porte le média et
partant de là la rédaction ensuite à sa
marge de manœuvre dans le fonctionnement
actuel des médias l'éditeur il est pas
tout le temps derrière leur rédaction
pour regarder ce qu'il écrit en revanche
dans cette dans ce même article 6 le 6b
nous semble très intéressant et là nous
nous écrivons complètement c'est de
prévenir les conflits d'intérêts et
d'être de garantir la révélation de tout
conflit d'intérêt réels ou potentiel ça
ça nous semble vraiment quelque chose
d'utile nous avons lors de la de
l'audition sur la concentration des
médias nous devions-nous attirer
l'attention sur les le fait que le
problème en France n'est pas tant la
concentration des médias mais le fait
que les et que des médias beaucoup de
médias appartiennent à des groupes qui
dont l'activité principale n'est pas
n'est pas la presse mais toute autre
chose
des armes au Télécom et donc les
conflits d'intérêts dans ce type de
situation peuvent exister donc avoir un
garde-fou par rapport à ces conflits
d'intérêt nous semble aussi très
intéressant par rapport
aux plateformes aussi
il a été rappelé ce problème de de
retrait des contenus unilatéral par les
plateformes là-dessus nous souscrivons
nous souscrivons à ce qui a été dit
concernant
la nécessité d'avoir un dialogue avec
les fins de pouvoir réagir et de d'être
considéré
comme de la presse alors vous avez
Jean-Pierre decarol a rappelé la
question de bien reconnaître les titres
de presse en vertu en France de la CPPP
on rajoute une chose nous on a dans la
loi de 81
la loi de 81 c'est la liberté
d'expression de tous les citoyens pas
seulement de la presse c'est à dire que
la loi de 81 elle ne distingue pas des
titres de presse la loi de 81 c'est
vraiment l'expression des citoyens des
éditeurs des citoyens et et là c'est
pour nous un petit le problème que pose
que poserait en fait le traitement
prioritaire des médias au delà même de
distinguer les médias est-ce que c'est
un média cPPA P ou pas qui certes est
important c'est important aussi de de
liste de pouvoir
de veiller à ce que un
citoyen ou un lanceur d'alerte qui
s'exprime sur des plateformes ne puisse
pas voir son contenu retiré d'une
manière unilatérale et qu'il est lui
aussi le moyen une instance pour réagir
qu'il y ait lui aussi droit à une
procédure contradictoire
et juste pour insister sur ce point du
rapport avec les plateformes là-dessus
malgré tout ce règlement mais vraiment
l'accent sur quelque chose qui est
absolument nécessaire c'est que nous
avons en France un problème enfin dans
tous les pays nous avons un énorme
problème avec les plateformes c'est
qu'elles sont totalement soustafées dans
les pays pour pouvoir réagir par rapport
à ces questions de contenu nous avons
nous des éditeurs plusieurs éditeurs qui
ont eu des problèmes de de compte
pirater de compte enfin de des tas de
problèmes et qui ne peuvent pas avoir
d'interlocuteur dans les plateformes
parce que il y a une personne qui est
censée être relation avec les médias une
personne qui est censée mais en fait ces
personnes là sont toutes seules pour
tout le pays donc elles sont évidemment
pas du tout disponibles donc même si on
peut avoir év leur téléphone portable ça
sert strictement à rien elle ne
répondront jamais et donc là on a
vraiment un problème peut-être que
au-delà même de ce règlement la France
pourrait légiférer pour exiger d'avoir
un interlocuteur un interlocuteur pour
les médias et un interlocuteur aussi
pour tous les citoyens enfin il faut que
les citoyens qui voient leur compte
usurper qui voient leur contenu
supprimer d'une manière totalement
arbitraire puisse réagir je pense que
j'ai déjà parlé longtemps donc
j'arrêterai là on a d'autres beaucoup
d'autres marques mais c'était vraiment
les points essentiels
alors pour la déontologie Monsieur
Patrick
voilà merci monsieur le Président bon je
recommence pas les formules de politesse
évidemment il y a un trouble dans les
andains comme aurait dit
Boris Vian et que les sénateurs
connaissent bien parce que les andains
ce sont les
les raies de de foin que l'on coupe et
qui sont parallèles je parle pour les
représentants des provinces françaises
qui connaissent bien cela il y a un
trouble dans les andains pourquoi
premièrement parce que l'Europe veut
appliquer
le même système à trois ensembles
démocratiques différents d'un côté les
démocraties il libérales de l'Europe de
l'Est et se sont elles qui sont visées
en premier évidemment et évidemment
qu'il faut faire quelque chose pour Léon
roi pour etc etc bien mais il y a cela
ou le pouvoir est où les oligarques
contrôlent de fait les médias en entend
absolument entre les deux et donc là où
il y a un vrai problème et où l'Europe
veut agir mais ne peut pas agir ce
dirigeant directement contre un pays
essaie de d'assimiler à l'ensemble
deuxièmement il y a les démocraties
libérales classique qu'on pourrait
mettre dans l'Europe du Nord l'Allemagne
etc etc où il y a évidemment pas de
problème bon quelques-uns de temps en
temps il y a forcément toujours des
problèmes
humains trop humain mais bon et puis les
démocraties libérales instables
je les appelle comme ça je mettrai
dedans la France et l'Italie
qui sont sur des
qui sont entre les deux quoi pour
l'instant bon puis on pourrait peut-être
me remettre d'autres alors comment
conjuguer comment concilier comment
aligner la Hongrie l'Allemagne et la
France
OK
bien ceci d'autant plus que
l'Europe enfin le règlement considère
que
le marché des médias est européen alors
que pas du tout il est soit complètement
international les grandes plateformes
Murdoch tout ce que vous voulez
bertholtzman bon soit il est très peu
européen j'ai essayé de recenser il y a
Rosel qui est franco-belge OK
il y a Springer quelques intérêts un
petit peu partout un petit peu partout
mais qui se tourne de plus en plus vers
les États-Unis bertolsman qui se qui
cherche à se retirer de tout et
malheureusement
nous l'Autorité de la concurrence n'a
pas accepté qu'il vende RTL et M6 à TF1
ce qui leur a permis de se
débarrasserite Jess media info
invest de crétinski qui qui est à cheval
sur la Tchéquie et sur sur la France et
puis Mediaset
Berlusconi Italie Espagne et Vivendi
mais pas Vivendi Canal+ seulement qui
qui rayonne sur mes mais qui est un pôle
de divertissement uniquement et qui
n'exporte que Canal+ mais qui n'exporte
pas
C8 cnews heureusement
ils ont pas encore trouvé le Hanouna
polonais mais ils vont finir par le
trouver
bien il y a donc la véritable il y a une
véritable question de on sent bien que
la
les rédacteurs de ce règlement sont
embêtés parce qu'ils veulent évidemment
viser les
îles libéraux d'abord et préserver alors
bon deuxième point et c'est ce qui
marque évidemment le plus c'est le
Comité européen pour les services de
médias
alors mes collègues
surtout Jean-Pierre je t'appelle
Jean-Pierre depuis des années
évidemment va hurler d'après ce que je
vais dire mais bon constituer par les
régulateurs nationaux de visuels les
regards etc pourquoi pourquoi laisser de
côté la presse
à l'heure de la convergence généralisée
où tout le monde presse radio télé
internet fait de la presse radio télé
internet je dis toujours à mes amis de
la presse que un jour où l'autre l'arcom
va s'emparer de vos podcasts puisque
théoriquement vous les podcasts
devraient être régis par là comme
pourquoi pas à l'heure de la convergence
généralisée on va voir pourquoi il y a
pas on fait tout pourquoi ne pas
adjoindre à cette
ergat transformé
les conseils de presse ou de déontologie
et c'est là en sens là que je prêche
évidemment pour ma boutique vous l'avez
bien compris comme chacun est si près je
pousse pour sa boutique bon
faut être clair vous le connaissez vous
avez l'habitude des lobbies donc
je prêche pour ma boutique il faut y
intégrer les conseils de presse il y a
20 conseils de presse en Europe
dans l'Union européenne sur 27 pays il
suffirait on pourrait on peut imaginer
un comité européen pour les services des
médias détachés de la commission
complètement indépendante avec
trois ensembles le les regards
transformés ou pas transformés les
l'aipce l'Association internationale des
sessions européennes des conseils de
presse et puis et moi j'y tiens beaucoup
des personnalités qualifiées
indépendantes des chercheurs des
universitaires des etc je parle pas pour
moi je veux pas en faire partie c'est
pas du tout mon problème je suis pas
dans ce cas-là mais on pourrait avoir
ces trois collèges qui pourraient être à
géométrie valable et là on pourrait
vraiment discuter de l'ensemble de ce
qui pose problème dans la liberté des
des médias des rédactions etc
bon petite analyse de texte laquelle je
me suis livré bêtement comme ça
j'ai pris des mots alors par exemple
régulation cité 154 fois dans les et
l'autorégulation seulement 18 fois
voyez on veut la régulation forcément
les regards l'arcom a un pouvoir de
coercition que n'ont pas les conseils de
presse qui n'ont que un émane
l'indépendance cité 129 fois le
pluralisme 73 73 fois mais ils ne se
font pas partie des définitions de
l'article 2 du règlement on ne définit
pas l'indépendance on ne définit pas le
pluralisme
est-ce que c'est le pluralisme interne
est-ce que c'est le pluralisme externe
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance
des médias des journalistes de de quoi
est-ce que si je puis dire je fais les
usages écrits des consommateurs aucune
occurrence les
usages n'existent pas dans cette
réglementation c'est un peu étonnant
la convergence 11 occurrents seulement
c'est aussi un peu un problème et puis
on va être quasiment sur un pied
d'égalité entre la liberté et la
concentration liberté cité 62 fois
seulement
62 fois seulement en 50 et je sais pas
combien de pages la concentration 65
comment
et la concentration 54 fois et là il y a
évidemment
quelque chose qui par exemple au
paragraphe 20 la ligne éditoriale a fait
l'objet d'un accord entre les
propriétaires et les chefs de rédaction
c'est un tout petit peu simpliste
une rédaction
et un public et ce enfin je l'ai déjà
dit pour quand j'ai été auditionné vous
souvenez monsieur Laffont sur
sur la concentration mais tant qu'on
tient pas compte de ça on ne comprend
rien aux médias
c'est le paragraphe 40 et les articles
21 22 qui portent sur la concentration
reflète sur ce sur ce sujet une pensée
particulièrement indigente je le
maintiens il y a il y est entretenu une
confusion permanente entre concentration
et menace sur l'indépendance et le
pluralisme
par exemple le droit de refuser
l'arrivée d'un nouvel actionnaire
et la viabilité des entreprises
si les journalistes du Monde avaient
refusé l'arrivée de berger pigasnier que
tu cultive fait en 2010
ils auraient mis la clé sous la porte
bon
monsieur je vais vous demander de
raccourcir un petit peu
qu'on puisse vous poser des questions
ensuite alors
évidemment évidemment il arrive voir
Bolloré que des actionnaires soient
toxiques mais ils ne sont pas tous même
quand ils sont concentrés toxiques c'est
là où il y a véritablement une confusion
bon voir la commission que vous avez
présidé monsieur Lafont donc on va pas y
revenir mais et puis c'est pas forcément
une question de concentration Monsieur
Nicolas Barré directeur de la rédaction
de des échos qui se fait virer par son
propriétaire enfin c'est pas le
propriétaire mais c'est le l'éditeur
comme dirait Monsieur Jean-Pierre vêtu
de keraoud mais l'éditeur il est sous la
houlette du propriétaire
directement comme ça c'est pas une
question de concentration Bernard
Arnault il a un tout petit groupe de
médias 300 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires 300
000 exemplaires vendus chaque jour
entre les deux quotidiens
c'est un tout petit groupe de médias
c'est pas de la concentration ou bien
alors il va falloir qu'on définisse de
concentration
que même même pour atteindre Bolloré moi
j'ai fait le calcul Bolloré si on prend
toutes les audiences y compris du groupe
la Gardère on atteint 9% d'audience
alors si on doit descendre en dessous de
9 % l'audience pour bloquer Bolloré
d'abord on bloque toutes les capacités
de fusion future les capacités
d'absorption futures et ensuite il faut
heureusement les lois ne sont pas
rétroactives mais il faut à ce moment-là
dégommer TF1 et pourquoi pas France
Télévisions qui est à 30% de l'audience
hein bon ça pose un vrai problème donc
il y a la véritablement je je vais en
conclure je vais conclure très
rapidement
il y a la véritablement un problème de
de
pour pour
bien d'où ça vient on a toute une série
de personnes notamment en France qui
prône contre les concentrations etc ça
sans savoir que c'est l'important c'est
la toxicité éventuelle du propriétaire
ou de la concentration c'est pas la
concentration en elle-même c'est même
pas la propriété en elle-même on peut
être
vendeur d'avions de chasse et d'armement
comme le groupe d'assaut et garder le
Figaro comme il était avant et comme il
sera après c'est-à-dire un journal
conservateur de droite catholique machin
etc mais le journal n'a pas changé parce
que il a été racheté par Dassault bon
donc il faut bien voir que c'est même
pas une question de propriété c'est une
question alors comment définir la
toxicité là c'est un vrai problème
là c'est un vrai problème parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il y a une toxicité chez un
notamment pour ne pas le citer le groupe
Bolloré bon voilà
alors après il y a quelques petites
remarques comme ça je termine je termine
je termine juste on parle d'information
fiables et de médias de qualité qui fera
le distinguer le JTI mais moi je pense
que le label est parfaitement
contre-productif à partir du moment où
vous mettez un label
ça veut dire que vous êtes du côté pour
ceux qui sont complotistes et autres
vous êtes du côté du pouvoir vous êtes
des donc par définition des méchants
parce que vous avez de la belle
on parle de réguler l'offre de contenu
médiatique
quid de la liberté évidemment il y a des
gens qui ne me plaisent pas dans
certaines télés dans certaines radios
dans certaines presses mais je pense
qu'il plaise à l'autre et la liberté
elle est au prix de la contradiction du
pluralisme de etc etc bon voilà alors
par contre effectivement sur les mesures
d'audience les publicités d'État
protection des sources oui oui toujours
oui pour les garde-fous à condition de
les mettre vraiment avec de peser avec
un trébuchet et avec finesse parce que
il faut faire très attention voir la
tripartition évoquée plus haut
enfin la transparence je vous rappelle
que dès 2009 j'avais proposé c'est dans
le le rapport du sénateur Michel
Thiolière du 4 novembre 2009 j'avais
proposé c'était une loi visant à réguler
la concentration dans le secteur des
médias déjà en 2009 après l'état général
de la presse j'avais proposé qu'on crée
un observatoire européen du pluralisme
et de la transparence dans les médias
et où on pourrait agglomérer toute une
série de choses mais je le tiens à votre
disposition j'ai déjà cité il est aussi
je suppose dans votre dans le rapport
Lafont à souligne merci de m'avoir
écouté monsieur un prisme un peu plus
international peut-être demander à
Monsieur Deloire donc de s'exprimer
maintenant alors je le dis en bulle en
essayant de respecter le temps parce que
ce qui va être important aussi c'est
l'échanger je vais m'y attacher
j'entends que ce cette proposition de
texte qui est imparfaite suicide
beaucoup de scepticisme et pas seulement
dans cette salle de la part des l'Ender
allemand de la part cette dernière
semaine des éditeurs nordiques et de
leur association
de la part d'historien des médias
et sans doute y a-t-il effectivement sur
ton articles matière
à amendement
y compris sur des aspects évoqués par
Monsieur de keraoul ou madame Dubois
néanmoins il y a là une formidable
opportunité
et il me semble qu'il serait dommageable
que le Sénat
s'attache à une position défensive
au dépend d'une position plus offensive
à un moment où clairement il y a un
enjeu majeur et où l'Union européenne
alors quelle que soit les espèces
juridiques et que j'entends absolument
mais peut jouer un rôle
y a-t-il un marché intérieur des médias
européens moi j'aurais tendance à dire
le marché des médias n'existe plus
vraiment
au sens où les médias sont
enfin qu'est-ce qu'on entend par média
mais si on entend par média les médias
d'information les médias producteurs de
journalisme je crois que c'est ce dont
on parle ici
ces médias aujourd'hui produisent des
contenus qui se retrouvent dans l'espace
numérique en concurrence directe avec
des contenus produits par toutes sortes
de producteurs
propagandistes formatrol industrie de la
désinformation citoyens scientifiques
faisant des
vidéos passionnantes
corrupteur d'informations du positif du
négatif mais en tout cas une concurrence
de toutes sortes de contenus contre tous
les autres indices
et le marché européen ou national
n'existe plus tellement au sens où
l'espace public désormais numérisé et
globalisée et n'a pas aujourd'hui de
frontières sauf celle mise par les
régimes d'esthétiques qui vise à clore
leur espace public et à l'intérieur à
contrôler l'information
et donc j'ai envie de vous dire prenons
l'occasion de ce texte et que le Sénat
dans le rapport qu'il produira prenne
l'occasion de ce texte pour poser une
vision de long terme et poser des
propositions qui peuvent changer la
donne
parce que si on regarde les évolutions
tendancières le risque c'est que du fait
de l'organisation de l'écosystème le
financement des médias deviennent de
plus en plus difficiles c'est normal ils
sont en concurrence aujourd'hui déloyale
avec d'autres producteurs de contenu
que le
ce qu'on estime être le journalisme si
on ne le regarde que lui et si on
s'attache à le défendre mais sans tenir
compte du reste on finissent par des
fentes une partie qui est en train de
s'effondrer
un certain nombre de points sur lequel
sur lesquels il y a matière soit avancée
soit
à amender effectivement la question des
des de la définition des médias et de
leurs obligations
comment éviter la capture oligarchique
et quel que soit le rôle des éditeurs la
capture oligarchique le danger de la
capture oligarchique il est réel
donc s'il y a un certain nombre de
problèmes dans
la rédaction actuelle de l'article y
compris le problème de traduction
d'ailleurs sur la question des décisions
individuelles
qui de l'onglet vers le français
il y a matière à mettre en place des
processus pour garantir non pas
l'indépendance des rédactions mais
l'indépendance éditoriale du journalisme
et qu'il a est un enjeu majeur qui peut
passer par des aspects procédure
de processus ou par des mesures visant
par exemple à introduire des notions
telles que des formes de trafic
d'influence dans le champ de
l'information
on a formulé des propositions de ce
sujet la deuxième question qui est celle
du rapport aux plateformes et je rejoins
Jean-Pierre dequeral ou sur ce point
qu'aujourd'hui les plateformes alors non
plus ou n'auront plus à partir du 1er
janvier 2024 au moment de la mise en
œuvre du DSA toutes les droits mais le
DSA est plutôt orienté à supposer qu'il
soit bien
appliqué sur la distinction entre licite
et l'illicites et pas tellement sur
l'organisation du chant du lycée
et où là l'article 17 aujourd'hui qui
prévoit simplement que les plateformes
feront tout leur possible pour prévenir
à l'avance de décision de modération
c'est un engagement dérisoire au regard
des enjeux la question c'est comment
fait-on pour que les plateformes d'une
certaine manière puisse protéger
l'information journalistique
puissent même lui redonner une forme
d'avantage comment on peut amplifier la
fiabilité de l'information
et de ce point de vue là il y a besoin
de forme de distinction on a besoin et
les différents intervenants évoqués on a
besoin aujourd'hui de distinguer ce qui
relève du journalisme ce qui n'en relève
pas et ça tous les parlements du monde
sont confrontés à ce sujet là si on fait
pas ça on n'arrivera pas à réintroduire
un mécanisme de promotion de la
fiabilité dans l'espace public
la journaliste qui a été cité à
plusieurs
occasions est un moyen non
discrétionnaire
sans organe qui décide qui est
journaliste qui ne l'est pas
puisque c'est sur la base du norme
désormais européenne édité
sous-egies du Comité européen
normalisation par des représentants très
différents d'éditeurs
de journalistes d'associations de
consommateurs de diverses associations
qu'une norme transparente qui peut faire
l'objet de vérification de la conformité
des médias par le marché de la
certification qu'un marché régulé en
Europe et au territoire qui est assez
proche de la CPPAP mais qui peut avoir
cet avantage d'être reconnu par les
plateformes à l'échelle internationale
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la CPPAP puis
l'autre problème de la CPAP c'est de ne
pas tenir compte aujourd'hui de la
convergence médiatique et du fait que il
y a une convergence de la télévision de
la radio enfin des différentes formes de
médias sur l'espace numérique
est déjà cité
explicitement et implicitement dans le
projet de emfa
l'enjeu serait de donner obligation aux
plateformes d'utiliser des tel mécanisme
de promotion de la fiabilité de
l'information j'attire votre attention
sur une chose c'est qu'il y a eu la
Commission européenne la négocié avec
les plateformes numériques et d'autres
acteurs un code de conduite contre la
désinformation il y a un engagement qui
l'engagement numéro 22 qui est un
engagement léger qui demandait aux
plateformes de mettre en place des
indicateurs de fiabilité de
l'information
ce texte a été négocié avec elle mais
les plateformes vous le savez pouvaient
signer tel ou tel engagement et ne pas
souscrire aux autres une seule sur les
14 possibles à souscrit cet engagement
on est aujourd'hui dans la situation les
plateformes numériques refusent de
prétendre mener des opérations contre
les informations sont en fait comme vous
le savez au moment même où il y a des
obligations des nouvelles obligations du
fait du DSA de licencier toutes leurs
équipes dites custom safety celle qui
devrait traiter de ces sujets là c'est
en train de se désarmer
et ne veulent pas surtout s'engager sur
ce qui est fondamental c'est que nos
espaces publics démocratiques ont été
construits parce qu'il y avait des
mécanismes à travers la régulation des
médias à travers l'autorégulation des
journalistes pour favoriser la fiabilité
de l'information et le MFA est vraiment
une occasion pour faire ça et ce serait
dommage de rater cette occasion
troisième chose
c'est l'occasion aussi le MFA de mettre
en place avec un mécanisme de protection
des espaces informationnels
démocratiques
sur la base de système de réciprocité
tel que nous l'avons proposé
qui est défendu déjà par des états nous
devons trouver des moyens pour que les
ingérences étrangères puissent être
traitées sur le fondement
d'un cadre juridique et pas sur des
décisions comme c'était le cas au début
de la guerre en Ukraine des décisions
sur la baisse de sanction économique de
la part de la Commission européenne il
faut créer un cas de juridique
spécifique pour traiter de cette
question là pour trouver une troisième
voie entre la refragmentation des
espaces publics des espaces numériques
et le maintien d'une ouverture
des démocraties tandis que les
dictatures elles sont fermées et mènent
des opérations de déstabilisation
voilà pour trois propositions c'est
l'occasion ce texte de mettre en place
un régime de responsabilité pour les
différents acteurs des droits et des
devoirs qui doivent sont pas les mêmes
pour les différents types d'acteurs et
puis enfin je rejoindrai aussi
différents intervenants sur le fait que
sans doute y a-t-il eu une
erreur enfin qui est un peu dommageable
au moment de l'établissement du DSA qui
est le rôle très important très très
important d'évoluer à la Commission
européenne elle-même là il s'agit bien
de dégager les décisions sur ces
questions de toute influence politique y
compris évidemment de la Commission
européenne elle-même merci
voilà
merci c'est pas évident de parler en
dernier parce qu'évidemment énormément
de d'éléments ont déjà été apportés je
vais essayer de ne pas les répéter mais
de dire ce à quoi éventuellement
souscrit peut-être juste avant de
démarrer parce que je ne suis pas sûr
que l'Association des gens listes
européens soient peut-être connus un
petit peu dans son fonctionnement parce
qu'on a une effectivement une je dirais
une mission d'observation et on
recueille énormément de de
le vécu en fait des journalistes à
travers l'Europe donc là on passe
effectivement à une dimension qui est
moins française et même si Christophe
Delor a rappelé un certain nombre
d'éléments au niveau européen et donc
l'age et l'Association des gens Histor
européens c'est la section française de
la sociation of yourpillage la ej nous
on compte 43 membres en France mais la
ej compte une vingtaine de sections et
plus d'un millier de journalistes elle a
été créée en 62 dans les six pays de de
l'époque elle a été fondée par six
journalistes qui étaient convaincu la
nécessité d'une intégration européenne
de manière démocratique et qui croyait
au potentiel donc du journalisme pour
promouvoir l'harmonie européenne et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont ils défendent
la liberté de l'information
et avec les au-delà des sections comme
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure il y
a une représentation dont de l'AEG
donc auprès du Conseil de l'Europe et
également auprès des institutions
européennes c'est d'ailleurs le un autre
vice-président de l'AJE présent à
Bruxelles qui qui travaille en ce moment
on a organisé une grande conférence en
décembre 2019 sur les libertés des
médias en Europe avec la RSF notamment
et en partenariat avec l'UNESCO et
l'ambassade de Suède à l'Unesco ici je
dis ça c'est parce qu'on observait déjà
à ce moment-là une très forte
dégradation de la situation et des
conditions de travail et des
journalistes à peu près partout en
Europe y compris sauf peut-être dans des
pays nordiques voilà la Norvège étant le
premier pays où je crois que la liberté
de la presse et la demeure à peu près
intouchés au jour d'aujourd'hui mais
sinon ça se dégrade dans pas mal de pays
la France y compris et donc je pense
qu'il n'a jamais été aussi difficile en
Europe d'exercer le métier de
journaliste je tiens à le redire parce
que ça n'est pas uniquement
effectivement même si on l'a rappelé des
questions de concentration des questions
de évidemment de de qui possèdent les
médias et de collusion dans un certain
nombre de pays entre les pouvoirs
publics un certain nombre de médias
audiovisuel public mais pas que et et
une difficulté je pense à informer de
façon totalement indépendante je
rappelle aussi que ce qui guette aussi
beaucoup les journalistes c'est
l'autocensure et l'autocensure elle
vient pas de nulle part et je pense que
la question démocratique qui se pose au
sein de chaque pays
énormément sur la liberté d'écrire et
d'informer sans s'autocensurer
évidemment il y a plein d'exemples j'ai
pas les nommer ici d'ingérence on vient
on voit bien que aux échos la SDJ vient
de publier une note se disant très
inquiète sur l'indépendance des médias
et j'y reviendrai
de son média je reviendrai rapidement
également sur cette question de
directeurs de la rédaction et de la
rédaction qui me paraît un point de
vigilance important donc la situation
elle est elle est elle est très très
dégradée ça c'est évident et je salue
tout de même si il est évident que la
Commission européenne a en tête des
régimes il libéraux et donc ce règlement
a été je pense écrit en grande partie en
réponse à ce qui est en train de se
passer en gris en Pologne et je rappelle
je pense que Christophe pourra le
corroborer que en fait on grise qui est
intéressant comme exemple c'est qu'il y
a pas de journaliste la maison en fait
la façon d'influer et d'empêcher les
médias d'exister c'est évidemment de les
fermer on a des exemples en date que je
vais pas citer je pense que j'ai pas le
temps mais j'avais envie ceci dit d'en
parler de médias indépendants qui sont
considérés comme des agents étrangers et
des agents de l'extérieur qui
empêcheraient
de mener sa politique
de façon souveraine donc
la façon de de museler la presse
l'indépendance de l'information elle est
protéiforme et pas une seule façon de
faire il y en a plein c'est pas
forcément de mettre les journalistes en
prison ou les assassiner même si ça on a
eu encore des assassinats très récents
dans des pays y compris aux Pays-Bas
donc il y a pas besoin d'aller très loin
en fait pour s'apercevoir que les pires
moyens existent partout mais il existe
une multitude de façon en fait
d'empêcher la pluralité de l'information
parce que c'est comme ça dont on parle
et je pense que
on est d'accord que les objectifs sont
louables je pense qu'il y a des bonnes
choses et là sais pas je ne peux pas
m'exprimer au nom de la uj parce que
j'ai pas mandat à représenter les vins
sections
ni même au sein de la Jie même si on
suit ça de très très près et il y a des
je pense une reconnaissance avec ce
cette écriture de ce règlement d'une
situation de très grande fragilité de la
presse on sait pas très bien par quel
boule prendre c'est-à-dire c'est très
touffu et c'est c'est parfois préfi
précis parfois je pense que ce règlement
a besoin d'un certain articles d'être
précisé effectivement comme vous l'aviez
nommé là tout à l'heure sur l'article 6a
entre la distinction entre directeur de
la rédaction et d'acteur en chef parce
que même si un directeur de la rédaction
protège ses journalistes évidemment s'il
est s'il est une marionnette ou une
semi-marionnette des actionnaires ils ne
protège qu'à moitié il est lui-même pris
dans des conflits d'intérêt donc la
situation de la presse en fait elle est
dégradée parce que la plupart des
rédactions n'ont plus les moyens
de travailler ils sont sous cette
affaire comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
il y a une difficulté en fait à
continuer d'exister pour un certain
nombre de médias indépendants ça n'a pas
été tellement soulevé mais au-delà des
questions de concentration de la presse
et de qui possèdent parmi les grands
groupes industriels les médias il y a
une question en fait de difficultés
économiques évidentes une baisse du
nombre de correspondants dans à peu près
tous les pays et à peu près dans toutes
les rédactions sauf à l'exception des
très grosses rédactions qui ont les
moyens de fonctionner et du coup la
le problème de la concentration c'est
aussi le problème de la de la de la
perte de tout un maillage de médias
indépendants on le voit en gris il
existe beaucoup de médias indépendants
en fait mais qui pour des raisons je
dirais
beaucoup plus dramatique dans ce pays
n'arrive plus à émettre parce que ils
sont fermés ils sont accusés ils sont
pas mis en prison mais simplement ils
sont dans la capacité de continuer à
faire leur travail et donc dans dans la
si vous voulez dans la dans la dans ce
règlement qui est qui est proposé ce qui
peut paraître tout de même un
intéressant c'est de de nommer en fait
ces conflits d'intérêt qu'on retrouve
dans chaque pays et quand on parle de
marché européen des médias je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec Christophe de Loire
que je sais pas si on peut parler
aujourd'hui de marcher européen puisque
le marché a tellement changé avec
l'importance la préminence des
plateformes qu'on n'arrive pas à réguler
et qui finissent par devenir en fait le
l'instance de de certaines régulations
infinie de des contenus de presse il y a
il y a la difficulté en effet de
soutenir et de renforcer le pluralisme
la pluralité et la diversité des médias
mais aussi l'indépendance des médias
parce que il existe des médias
indépendants un peu partout en Europe
qui sont plutôt en train de fermer la
porte
j'ai pas le temps de donner des exemples
et peut-être on y reviendra et ça c'est
assez dramatique pour la qualité de
l'information ensuite peut-être je
rentre pas dans les détails mais je suis
d'accord avec Cécile Dubois que
l'article 6b me paraît nous paraît tout
à fait intéressant
la question des plateformes est un point
de vigilance énorme je suis pas sûr
qu'il le règlement il réponde exactement
mais en tout cas c'est un c'est ce que
le fait dans débattre me paraît déjà
quelque chose qui est plutôt une avancée
je comprends la crainte qu'on peut avoir
au niveau des parlements
nationaux d'être dépourvu de en fait de
sa capacité à réguler le marché des
médias par contre on a en Europe une
énorme différence dans les cadres
législatifs alors si on a un cadre
législatif fort en France de par cette
loi notamment 1880 dans d'autres pays il
est extrêmement faible ma question c'est
un cadre légitime très faible en Hongrie
par exemple ou en Pologne est-ce que ce
règlement va régler si je puis dire la
question ça j'avoue que je je ne sais
pas je voudrais juste terminer après on
reviendra peut-être si on a encore un
peu de temps avec les questions sur le
le périmètre en fait de l'information
qu'il ne faut pas circonscrire
uniquement aux médias je pense au
lanceur d'alerte et évidemment mais je
pense aussi à toutes l'émergence de de
de victime de podcasts ou de
d'informations relativement
approfondie qui ne sont pas forcément
uniquement produits par des médias
traditionnels je pense que c'est
l'information et la circulation d'une
information plurielle que que auquel il
faut réfléchir le règlement n'y répond à
mon sens qu'à moitié mais le fait de le
nommer dans des battre me paraît très
important et en fait pour finir il n'y a
peut-être pas de marché nationaux non
plus des médias en tant que tel
uniquement puisque le l'importance de la
de l'information relation et de sa
qualité de la vérification pour la
qualité de la démocratie
fonctionne aussi de plus en plus en
regardant ce que font les voisins même
si on a réduit le nombre de
correspondants et même si
malheureusement des émissions sur
l'Europe notamment en France ont plutôt
tendance à diminuer qu'à augmenter et
donc le l'émergence d'un espace public
et civique européen puisque nous sommes
quand même au sein de de l'Union
européenne me paraît important à
préserver et bon je le dis aussi parce
que je suis co-fondatrice de Vox Europe
et nous avons un peu cette vocation mais
de faire circuler l'information dans
plusieurs langues et de ne pas s'arrêter
uniquement aux frontières je pense que
comme beaucoup d'autres grands thèmes
importants l'information ne s'arrête pas
non plus totalement frontières donc
réfléchir à avoir une instance auquel on
pourrait faire appel me paraît
intéressant mais il faut pas créer une
usine à gaz voilà merci
merci
sur je voudrais avoir quelques
éclaircissements enfin un
éclaircissement surtout sur un des
points enfin sur des mots que j'ai pu
entendre puisque on est tous attachés à
la liberté les médias à la protection
des journalistes
moi je voudrais savoir entre les mots
entre la liberté et la régulation il y a
tout un espace à mon avis l'espace
éthique de la déontologie
pour prendre des mots de Monsieur etno
les droits et les devoirs et moi il y a
une confusion j'entends toujours et je
trouve pas les choses étaient éclairées
c'est entre la différence entre
l'indépendance des médias et
l'indépendance des journalistes
et il y a une confusion permanente et on
se demande si c'est pas une façon de de
fuir ces responsabilités en tout cas
j'ai pas été plus éclairé parce que
chaque fois qu'on s'intéroge sur
l'indépendance des uns finalement la
réponse se fait dans le domaine quand on
parle de l'indépendance des journalistes
c'est on nous répond sur l'indépendance
des médias et inversement et je est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est le texte et
nous éclaire davantage je suis peut-être
prendre toutes les questions et puis
vous répondrez chacun sur les points que
sur lesquels vous souhaitez intervenir
André gatelin
oui merci je voulais rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire
Catherine André et que je partage
totalement pour avoir fait dans cette
commission en rapport il y a deux ans et
demi sur l'état de droit en Pologne
avoir rencontré beaucoup de responsables
de presse indépendante moi je crois la
question sincèrement qui fait que je
motive notre avis motivé c'est que les
instruments qui sont mis en place c'est
l'objectif de la Commission ne
permettent pas de lutter
efficacement contre le problème de la
liberté de la presse en Pologne je
m'entends d'ailleurs la Commission dans
le texte parle de l'attribution de
publicité d'État
l'attribution de publicités privées
aujourd'hui en Pologne il y a alors
l'oligarchie est un une vraie
explication le lien politique
extrêmement fort il y a deux centrales
d'achat d'espace qui sont complètement
aux mains d'amis le dirigeant du pouvoir
et qui décide qui ont droit de vie et de
mort mais c'est du privé alors la
commission là est dans la liberté
d'entreprendre selon ses principes et
ses bases juridiques c'est mon problème
c'est la manière dont la commission qui
cherche et c'est une bonne chose et
l'Union européenne à s'emparer des
questions d'État de droit qu'elle a
totalement négligé dans sa construction
historique le fait sur des bases et des
approches qui biaisent la capacité à
réfléchir de manière plus globale à
l'état droit et à ses fonctionnements
c'est pour ça que la référence au
Conseil de l'Europe c'est pas simplement
parce que j'y suis impliqué comme
d'autres parlementaires ce travail de
réflexion sur l'état droit la démocratie
et peut-être plus fort et mérite et le
cas de clubs radio il faut savoir que
c'est sa suspension est liée à deux
retards dans les délais de dépôt de
chansons de quotas de chansons
hongroise sur la radio
de de délai fait que la plus grosse
radio qui avait par ailleurs une
information indépendante c'est vu
complètement radié donc je crois que il
y a à creuser bien sûr il faut une
régulation mais je pense que
la question que vous avez soulevé des
définitions préalables des idées des
concepts alors on peut le faire de
manière quantitative en comptant les
mots comme comme ça a été fait c'est
important mais
on a un souci préalable un texte ne peut
pas tomber brut il doit donner des
justifications il doit clarifier les
objets et c'est là où je crois il y a un
rôle pour le Sénat mais aussi pour vous
à travers les différentes instances que
vous représentez du métier d'aider ou en
tous les cas de préciser ce qu'on entend
par indépendance des médias indépendants
du journalisme qualité du travail ou non
etc donc c'était plus un commentaire
pour dire qu'on est et puis sur la
question peut-être des directeurs de la
publication on oublie un est un double
support il y a un support de contenu et
d'information journalistique puis il y a
des contenus publicitaires qui en est
responsable un rédacteur en chef n'est
pas responsable du message publicitaire
qui alimente financièrement donc cette
question là à mon avis est pas simple à
poser parce que ça peut conduire le
directeur de la publication avoir
mais comme il a une responsabilité
finalement juridique avoir une forme
d'autorégulation par rapport à l'entrée
de moyens financiers
souhaitait poser une question oui merci
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour la clarté et surtout la
liberté de de vos propos on entend bien
je partage complètement le souci que on
doit aujourd'hui venir en aide aux
journalistes dans les pays où leurs
droits sont menacés mais comme il a été
dit aussi par ailleurs il ne faudrait
pas pour cela que ça
abaisse le niveau de protection dont on
dont on profite en France vous l'avez
dit très justement la loi de 1880 c'est
une loi de la liberté d'expression ce
qui est fondamental et moi je la relie à
la loi de 1901 sur la liberté
d'associations et 905 sur la liberté de
culte là on a la base le socle de l'État
de droit républicain français Les Trois
Glorieuses et je n'imagine pas que pour
combattre une certaine forme
d'illibéralisme à l'est de l'Europe on
puisse abaisser ces libertés donc est-ce
que vous aujourd'hui vous voyez une voie
de compromis qui permettrait d'une part
de garantir ce qui existe en France et
qui a montré quand même ça ce sont bon
fonctionnement parce que quand une une
loi doit date pardon de 1880 on peut
considérer qu'elle quand même rempli son
rôle pareil pour le 1905 et 1901 donc
comment les préserver tout en permettant
en effet de de conforter
la liberté des journalistes dans les
pays où ils sont où elle est menacé donc
on a besoin aussi de de votre diagnostic
sur cette fois moyenne que nous
pourrions défendre dans notre résolution
c'est-à-dire de ne pas attaquer
de façon un peu violente le règlement en
considérant qu'il est important mais
aussi faire comprendre à la commission
qu'on peut trouver une voie médiane pour
pour faire que les les deux choses
soient conciliables voilà c'était sans
doute une question compliquée mais je
pense qu'on doit se retrouver sur ce
terrain là pour avancer ensemble merci
je ne sais pas comment vous voulez sur
quel point vous voulez réagir ou
répondre et qui commence surtout
monsieur Decker
alors je voulais revenir sur
l'indépendance
l'indépendant on ne cesse de parler de
la dépendance sans jamais la définir
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance du média
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance de la
rédaction est-ce que c'est
l'indépendance du journalisme est-ce que
c'est la liberté du média la liberté de
la rédaction la liberté du journaliste
je vais vous citer Hubert buvemérique
qui était qui est le pape français de
tous les journalistes et des déontologie
journalistiques
qui disait à un moment quand à la
liberté de chacun dans l'entreprise on
sait très bien quand on entre dans un
journal quelle est la ligne générale de
celui-ci donc en principe on s'agrège à
une équipe dans laquelle on pense
pouvoir jouer un rôle sans trop avoir à
en souffrir et donc ce que je crains le
personnellement maintenant c'est que
chaque journaliste estime qu'il a le
droit d'étaler ses tripes sur la table
de penser et d'écrire ce qu'il veut en
fonction de ses sentiments ce n'est tout
même pas aussi simple donc
je reviens mon à ma triangulation parce
que je trouve que c'est fondamental et
que on
y attache pas assez d'importance
l'entreprise la rédaction et le public
c'est sans arrêt un jeu
l'entreprise recrute des journalistes
pour
fournir de l'information à un public
déterminé on sait très bien que on va
fournir de telles informations à un
journaliste un journée du Figaro et
l'entreprise Figaro va fournir des
informations différentes de l'entreprise
et de la rédaction et l'humanité et que
l'on parle pas de la même façon du pape
à Charlie Hebdo ou à la croix ça me
paraît pas poser un problème et on voit
bien que c'est parce que le public n'est
pas le même que les rédacteurs ne sont
pas les mêmes et que l'entreprise n'est
pas la même mais que c'est c'est ce
voyez c'est ce lien alors effectivement
il faut de l'indépendance mais il
faudrait la définir c'est indépendance
et et je trouve encore une fois que on
insiste trop sur le côté capitalistique
de l'indépendance alors que ce n'est pas
de cela dont il s'agit selon qu'il
s'agit c'est véritablement que la ligne
éditoriale et les fabriquer de façon
plus ou moins
conflictuelles entre la rédaction et
l'entreprise en tenant compte du public
qui va recevoir c'est le choix éditorial
effectivement le choix rédactionnel il
appartient à la rédaction il appartient
sous la direction d'un directeur de la
rédaction mais il a aussi il est dirigé
vers un public quand on parle de la
neige pendant une demi-heure sur TF1 et
pas de l'Ukraine c'est parce qu'on pense
que le public est plus intéressé par la
neige que par l'Ukraine
on peut le regretter mais c'est ainsi
donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a un
rapport bon et c'est pour ça que on voit
pas alors je me suis peut-être mal fait
comprendre moi je crois qu'effectivement
il faut une MFA
mais il faut vraiment la revoir de fond
en comble enfin pour toute une série de
raisons que j'ai essayé de vous
expliquer je crois que c'est très
important qu'on est enfin un fruit de
Mac en Europe tout à fait c'est très
important et je suis tout à fait
favorable simplement il faut il faut
revoir beaucoup de passage le dernier
point entre directives et règlement
l'avantage du règlement c'est que on
neblige pas les lois nationales à être
adaptées une directive soit obligé de
transcrire dans la dans la dans la et ça
prend des années des années etc etc
un règlement c'est d'application
immédiate mais on n'a pas besoin de
transcrire forcément dans la loi donc
c'est quand même beaucoup plus pratique
à ce niveau là
[Musique]